I'm sure V got to a certain point where
he's like I can't buy anything anymore
like what do I want and he's like well
maybe like one thing you can't buy
technically is a high ranking government
position although let's be real there's
a certain level where it's all for sale
and then there's a certain level where
it's not you know like being VP or
president is something you can only you
can buy a little bit of but you really
got to push the rest and then you've got
to basically sell promises to a bunch of
evil people but if you want to be an
ambassador a that's a cash deal after
the way he talked to the moderator last
night I was like he'd be a great press
secretary a lot of people are saying
that yeah but I don't think he'd want to
be press secretary I mean the thing that
I like about V is that he feels like he
wants to be in charge of something and I
think that's cool that he wants to sort
of contribute in that way I mean V's not
my choice president although I admire
him a lot he's great uh I have some I
would want him to be stronger on
restricting legal immigration I've said
that a million times everyone's bored of
this comment but it is fun to see him
out there right he is shaking up
politics